welcome to this video yeah this is
hopefully bit better than the warm-up
games I played to Hamid games where I
lost against ya some weaker position and
I lost horribly really like me totally
the idea so I'm hoping that this game
which I'm now recording no matter what
yes somewhat better playing against
Grandmaster riccardi from Argentina yeah
he's playing a somewhat rare line of
them of the classical nims Oh with c 5 9
a-6 this line has a quite dodgy
reputation to be perfectly honest but
it's not so easy to play for white
because of my bad development plus I
haven't looked at this form for a long
long time 94 maybe half my night b5 is a
very serious threat I'm gaining some
some time here the drawback from blacks
perspective years that he simply has
given up the bishop pair and he's got
the worse kind of structure here it's a
it's a hedgehog tab structure but
without the bishops especially the
ability is having Bishop it's not very
nice but I'm not very well developed
this is the the problem of this position
ok this I can hardly believe it makes
some sense of course that she opens it
up but hmm let's see now be form looks
normal
yeah opening up the position from my
former bishop pair it's something that I
don't really object to so i guess i'm
going to take the real question is now
what now of course my centers is hanging
here Bishop f4 would be would be nice
rook moves and then e five maybe I guess
that's good i'm brooke c3 e5 Knight h5
Bishop d2 rook takes g4 Anderson I'd
stripped yeah it's just it's just
blundering material here are giving it
away or whatever you may want to call it
the question is to see get some random
compensation for it I don't take it's
got its got two pawns it is clearly
better for wide but it is still two
points so not so easy the Knights might
hop to see form I can play rook a one
though this is a good move hatch or
exchanging his active rook that's good
this was his most active piece so I'm
trading this if it's just minor pieces
this will be relatively easy I think he
has to trade not quite sure what the
thing is here where where's the rook
going night see voice is no no serious
alternative can just take it on a three
I mean after which is night is totally
misplaced this is
he has to take a one right it's a kind
of curious thing
what see disconnected or something yeah
probably the penis is no success may be
disconnected that's possible yeah I mean
I'm not thinking about some kind of this
typical ragequit just a just the
connection glitch that can happen all
the time yeah as we will be awaiting
this was critical i think around TM the
look doesn't have many squares i was
thinking that i have e five anyway night
age five back because g4 threatens but
maybe forfeits due to this connection
yeah there was it wasn't the rage quit
it was something else some really some
real disconnection issue we have to
check around t i mean this this line has
a very bad reputation anyway for black a
bit surprising that the grandmaster
plays it it gives up a little bit too
much with the bishop center then setting
up a hedgehog yeah here as thought takes
takes i had a contest giving night f5s
very strong yeah that's in fear that is
interesting yes the point is that once
the computer wants to do this check very
very nice way to play check checkmate
meat which is easy to see actually this
kind of thing but the problem is that
here he also has other moves like 95 for
example after which we've probably will
take and then here yeah it's nice me now
I didn't consider 95 I just saw that
this should be good and yeah computer
agrees takes takes Bishop f4 and plus
1.6 ok
going back is better yeah this is what I
expected and then I wasn't sure about
when if I would go night f5 or e 5 both
looks very very feasible here I wasn't
sure what about this is this puzzle I
have four strong very strong is okay the
double attack then this is just just
very good yeah if I can just do this I
mean the night has no good square
somewhere and even hear my dad's
terrible and this is losing after you
five right yeah ruin and and white is
winning yeah this was yeah just just a
bad opening really after which have have
trouble this is simply not a good line
here this night a six nowadays this take
take take f3 is just much better than
before here there is this old move
before I mean odd move it some or from
the 90s let's say nowadays this line is
out of business anyway and this is what
they played back then after which there
is stuff like that after which black is
sacrificing a piece for for weird
compensation but it's not clear at all
but it is spent because it is now clear
that f3 is just good of course it takes
a long time for y to complete
development which is a constant problem
of the classical system here but if you
get the complete development you have an
excellent position area of the bishop
pair and the center and this is simply
not a not a good line Black now has to
do something I don't know I hope the
eight on some normal-looking move after
which you are just worse but of course
still not like you're losing immediately
it's just a second-rate type of position
that you have okay thanks for watching